Well, please help me with jam.
Hmm,
it
's a crime like that because you're not popular. Esse Penny, either scropping or running away
.  Music]
me Airon Norma Actually, it doesn't start. I
wonder if there
is a fool. I converted it to this card. By reading the knowledge first,
I want to focus on me and completely kill the magical way in the effect area.  I can
do this kind of thing,
while the correct answer of the shrine is the second generation
decision I wonder if it has reached that level
Invincible mountain that seals magic I can not do it first, but
3 Oh, even in the room, I am also in the effect area  Because there
is a magician, how do you fight with your own magic in a sealed manner? Let's take it away.
I'm tired of it, but I wonder if the tear was torn
.  I'll stab you at the end
is a place
aname
[Music]
Ah ah ah
Somehow there is something serious
[Music]